- "Zombieland: Double Tap" has arrived
and as of this taping
is coming in at 80% on the Tomatometer.
It's been nearly a decade since
the first "Zombieland" movie
delighted both fans and critics,
and the sequel according
to the critics consensus
is an enjoyable reunion
that recaptures the spirit
of the original and adds a few fun twists.
Hello everyone and welcome to
"The Rotten Tomatoes Show".
I am Mark Ellis, and I am so excited
to be talking about
"Zombieland: Double Tap" today.
We're gonna dive deep into the film.
Tell you all what we thought about it,
and yes it is a spoiler-heavy talk
so if you have not yet seen
the movie, you've been warned.
We have a great panel here.
These are three people I would really feel
comfortable surviving a
zombie apocalypse with.
So when I introduce you
please tell the audience
what your "Zombieland" name
would be, starting off with,
you know her from the Twisted
Woman CKR YouTube channel,
it is CKR, Chauncey K. Robinson is here.
Chauncey, how are you?
- I'm good, you?
- [Mark] I am great.
Your "Zombieland" name would be?
- Newark.
- Would be Newark.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Okay.
North Jersey.
- New-ark,
New Jersey.
- New-ark.
All right, there we go,
so we gotta go all the way
to New Jersey,
- Get it right.
- [Mark] to find Chauncey.
Sitting next to her on her left is,
he probably knows the month, day, and year
of the original "Zombieland" release.
- Actually I don't but I know it was 2009.
- October second.
- [Mark] Scott Mantz is here
and your "Zombieland" name?
- My "Zombieland" nickname,
I am very proud to say,
would be Philadelphia.
- [Mark] Okay, oh well
good we're picking up--
- Yep just a two-hour drive to Newark.
(laughing)
- [Mark] And last but certainly not least,
a returning favorite from Rotten Tomatoes,
Mr. Alex Vo is here.
- Hey, Alex here, I am from San Jose,
which is probably about a
30-hour drive from New Jersey.
- It's about 3,000 miles, yeah,
because I've made the drive
from Williamsburg, Virginia,
I'm gonna be Williamsburg--
- Williamsburg!
- So Williamsburg's first question
for the panel of great cities
that we have before us is
definitely is the movie
fresh, is the movie rotten?
Chauncey start with you, is
this a fresh or rotten movie?
- I think it's definitely fresh.
It expands the universe,
but it doesn't get away
from the core characters
that we love which I really appreciated.
- Very well said,
now Alex Vo, San Jose, are
you gonna to ratify the...
- I'm gonna say rotten.
- What?
- I expected nothing and
I was still disappointed.
- San Jose.
- Wow.
- Good thing you're far from Philadelphia,
that's all I gotta say about that.
- You get these west coasters crossed--
- It's a cross-cultural misunderstanding.
- So Philadelphia it seems
like you're going fresh.
- I'm going fresh, I'm
going fresh with Newark here
because I thought that the
movie just recaptured the spirit
and the fun of the original film
and it didn't really expand on it enough,
but we'll get to that,
but I still had a great time
just like I did with the first one.
- Yeah I'm going fresh as well.
I didn't think it was quite
as good as the first one,
but I thoroughly enjoyed myself
and there's a reason why they call them
the Sharks in San Jose because whoo,
we'll see what Alex's thoughts are
as we get deeper into the movie,
but Scott I wanna kick off
with you, the first topic
because anytime a sequel comes out
you have two questions that are out.
One, does it live up to the original,
and number two was it worth the wait?
We've been waiting 10
years for this movie.
- Okay, well, I'll do the
second question first.
Was it worth the wait?
I bought the first movie,
but I don't know if I
was waiting for a sequel.
It wasn't a movie where just I went,
man, let's go, two or three years,
let's have a "Zombieland" sequel
but I still had fun with it,
and here we are 10 years later,
I would say that the movie,
it's as good as the original
for what it does well with
the chemistry, with the fun,
with sort of the in-joke moments.
It doesn't really expand on
it, it doesn't capitalize,
it doesn't grow from the first movie,
but I still had just as
much fun as the original.
- Alex was that your issue,
is that it does not grow
from the original at all?
- That's not necessarily my issue.
I would agree with Scott
where it's asking me
was it worth the wait.
That would imply I was waiting
for a sequel in the first place.
The first one's great, it's fine,
but beyond that I was like awesome,
let's move on or let's do something else.
Whereas this one, yeah it's
like, the issue for me was,
most of the movie they
spend separated again,
and it's like I already seen that movie,
it's called "Zombieland" one.
I just wanted 'em thrown
together and sort of kicking ass,
but instead they're being
constantly separated
by these really specious reasons I felt.
- So a more united crew
is what you were hoping.
- You got a little bit of
that in the first 10 minutes
and then they just start
going off on their own again.
- Yeah, and Chauncey, what I liked is that
if you ask the question was
the movie worth the wait
I think we can all agree we weren't just
sitting by the computer waiting
for the news to be announced
but I think this movie had fun with that.
It started out light and fluffy,
it made a joke that there's
so many more zombie
options that you have now,
and then we rip into Metallica,
so I think the light and fluffiness
actually helped the movie.
- Yeah I mean I kinda considered it
a feel-good zombie picture.
I don't know if that's a thing,
but I think that totally is what it was,
and I think it was very aware of itself
that it had been so long.
They were like yeah we're back
and we know there's been
so much other stuff,
but that's okay 'cause
you love "Zombieland"
and I enjoyed it, I thought it was,
I actually think it's better
than the previous one,
but then again I didn't watch it in 2009
when the first one came out.
I watched it maybe in the last few years.
I wasn't anticipating anything,
and then I actually like
that they expanded it
because I didn't like all the
characters in the first one.
So it was good to kind of have
a different dynamic going on
even though I appreciated
the love of the core four.
It had family vibes.
- There was a lot of family vibes
in this movie and the locations we go to.
I did have a lot of
fun watching this movie
and it has been 10 years
and you really feel,
the way when you look
at the actor's resumes,
I mean Emma Stone now has an Oscar.
You see everything get done,
but it felt like as soon as
this as this movie started
we all just settled right back
into "Zombieland" from 2009.
- Big time, that's what I
loved about the film the most,
is that here you have Emma Stone,
Oscar winner for "La La Land".
- [Mark] Oh there he is, there he is,
the one segment before he referenced it.
- But she did fit right back
into that role of Wichita,
great chemistry with
Jessie Jesse Eisenberg,
and the thing about Jesse
Eisenberg, Oscar nominee,
he created Facebook as Mark Zuckerberg
in "The Social Network", but everyone,
Woody Harrelson hasn't aged at
all since the original film.
I mean he hasn't changed
his look at all in 20 years,
but yeah that family vibe
that you were talking about,
the heart, the chemistry, even
though they were separate,
which I think you have to
change it up a little bit,
I thought the addition
of the newer characters
also added to a different
sort of chemistry.
- Yeah and I wanted to move
into that for our next topic,
Alex, because when you
talk about the chemistry
that these four have, some of
the critics have been saying
that they didn't really
respond to the new characters
that were introduced,
that it did take away from
the core four a little bit
like you had some what I
thought were fun cameos
from Luke Wilson, Thomas Middleditch,
I thought Rosario Dawson was
a great addition to the cast.
Your feelings on the newcomer?
- I would agree Rosario
Dawson was a pretty
fucked up character
who had a lot going on.
Zoey Deutch's character Madison,
who spent 10 years in a
freezer I did not buy at all.
People talk about how great
Zoey Deutch was in the role.
I guess she is, but she's great
at playing a shit character.
I just could not--
- Wow.
- Yeah, I just could not stand
her character at all.
- My goodness.
(laughing)
Same with that dude introduced
for Abigail Breslin's character, that...
- Berkeley.
- Berkeley, the hippie dude.
I was confused as to
how any of these characters
survived 10 years,
15 years into a zombie apocalypse.
- [Scott] We're talking
about a zombie movie,
a zombie comedy.
- But what's great about "Zombieland" one
is you have a guy who's neurotic
and very rules-focused--
- [Scott] And he still lived.
- Right, but you buy that he can survive
in this sort of apocalypse.
Same with Tallahassee, same
with these two characters,
and when they kinda come together
they work really well,
whereas these two other characters,
it's hard for me to buy
them in our own reality.
- I can understand that point,
because if I'm watching
"Walking Dead", Chauncey,
and then somebody's been living
in a pink, hairy freezer for 10 years,
it seems like a stretch,
but for the tone of "Zombieland"
I thought particularly Zoey's character
stole a lot of scenes.
I thought Madison was there.
- Yeah, I love Madison.
I thought she was hilarious,
not just because of the
way she played the part
but because it was actually a
very strong kind of character,
just a different of strong we're used to
with she knew what she
wanted as soon as she wanted.
She was like I have a mission,
I'm gonna bite the bullet
through the old guy,
you don't wanna do it, she was very direct
and I just thought she was a lot of fun,
and I thought it was a good addition
to Nevada as well, Rosario Dawson,
because she had a strongness to her,
and it was very different
kind of woman characters added
which I appreciated.
- We do have to talk about
Rosario Dawson's character, Nevada.
Scott, it was such a breath
of fresh air seeing her
near Graceland not exactly in Graceland,
but at Graceland adjacent,
and she for my money's
the best monster truck driver
I think since Gravedigger.
- She is terrific in this film.
She's a big genre fan anyway,
but you can tell that she
was having a lot of fun.
Great chemistry especially
with Woody Harrelson.
I really thought that in terms
of adding new characters to this movie,
she was a worthy addition to
the "Zombieland" franchise.
- Yeah, Chauncey, for all the coupling
that could've gone on in this movie,
I was rooting for Rosario
and Woody the most.
- I shipped it, I totally
was there for them.
As soon as they met each other,
just her being there
and his love for Elvis
and her love for Elvis, I
wanna know the backstory
and how she ended up there, like why that?
She has the same kind of vibe that he did
and they just clicked immediately.
It didn't take long, I
totally believe the hookup,
I guess people, you know, it's zombie time
so they're looking for love,
so she found it with him,
and it was just awesome.
- Yeah, Alex, we're gonna talk about our
"Zombieland" future in a little bit here,
but I kinda like the
idea of a Nevada prequel.
- Talk about how she got the hotel
in the first place, right?
Did she, was it a heist
where she went to Graceland,
grabbed all the Elvis stuff
and brought it back over there,
but yeah I would agree, out
of all the new characters,
what she brought out of
Woody Harrelson's character,
and how she was sort of the nexus point
where you could bring in Thomas
Middleditch and Luke Wilson.
- I'm gonna just keep
the running joke going
with the "Zombieland" nicknames, San Jose.
I do agree that one flaw of the film
about the characters being separate,
is that when Abigail
Breslin as Little Rock,
was separated from the
rest of the core group
because she hooked up with Berkeley,
that was the weakest link of the film,
was her storyline with Berkeley,
it just didn't move the story along,
it didn't resonate nearly as much with me
as the other scenes with
the other characters.
- What I thought was how interesting,
Little Rock's arc is
actually really interesting.
Yeah she would want companionship
with someone her own age,
and what if that guy
that she hooked up with
was actually really interesting?
The whole time you're kinda waiting
for them to split up because this guy's--
- He's a poser.
- Right.
- Totally.
- So but what if there's
actually a change like,
what if she is actually
better off with these dudes.
- But I also thought if
you're really gonna see
how much time has passed,
I mean Abigail Brezlin,
she definitely has
matured into a young woman
and you're seeing her
completely different,
whereas the other characters
look pretty much the same.
So, I feel like you could've
done more with that,
and I felt like her character's storyline
was the weakest link of the
film, but I still like the film.
- I thought that part
was a little contrived,
but it was because they needed to get them
to go on a roadtrip,
if not we wouldve been
in the White House the
whole time, which I enjoyed.
- [Mark] I had a lot of
fun in the White House.
- [Scott] That was pretty good.
- But I actually thought it made sense
that she'd hook up with
a really crappy guy
because she hasn't been
with anyone for so long
it's like well this guy is kinda cute
so it's like she just runs off with him
I mean that's real life
to a certain degree.
- And then he ripped off Bob Dylan
and I thought that joke was so good
and it does make it more
convenient for the movie
that we all are rooting
against this relationship.
- Totally, that's a good point.
- We just wanna get our core four back.
Regardless of what people may say
about the Thomas Middleditch
or the Luke Wilson cameos,
I think we can all agree, that kill scene
was one of the best in the movie.
So I wanna talk about some
of y'alls favorite scenes,
if you have any,
Chauncey,
- Gotta rack my brain.
- Kick me off with one of your
favorite scenes from
"Zombieland: Double Tap".
- Well definitely that kill scene.
That was amazing.
I like a lot of the White House antics
and then the Bill Murray scene at the end.
The after credits kinda marvel style,
people were getting up,
but it was wow there's
something else going on,
it was an action scene,
I really thought that was
hilarious with everyone.
- People I know that all of us here,
you've been in that junket style
situation a number of times
so to see that lampoon,
I don't know how people who
do not work in the industry
are gonna receive that,
but Bill Murray's in it
so I'm pretty sure they're gonna love it.
- I just thought that they
keep the Bill Murray joke,
gag, the running joke going,
and it does have a great payoff.
That's definitely one of the best scenes
in terms of zombie kills.
I thought the zombie kill of the year,
with the guy on the
farm in the big tractor
munching up the zombie with this machine.
- [Mark] And the leaning
tower of Piza kill.
- Oh, that was awesome!
- Alex, you gotta love
the leaning tower of Piza.
- That was good, you know.
- Come on, San Jose,
you gotta love it.
- So what else stuck out to you?
Oh okay, well that's a redeemable
quality about the movie.
- I think the introduction
of Thomas Middleditch
and Luke Wilson were great actually.
I think those 25 minutes
where they're in the movie that's like--
- Really came alive.
- Yeah, thank you.
Like really came to life there.
Even the way the camera would swoop around
as they're being chased around
by the zombie versions, that
was beautiful camera work.
This is kinda what I was hoping for
throughout the whole movie,
but I would also agree with
the junket massacre at the end
where exactly everyone who's
sort of gone through that
it can be kinda numbing on both sides
so just seeing this chaos
erupt from it, pretty good.
- Quick sidebar so what was
the better Bill Murray scene.
Was it the Bill Murray scene
from the first Zombieland,
or was it this Bill Murray?
- This one.
- Oh, I'll go with first one.
- I'm goin' first one too.
- [Alex] 'Cause it was so unexpected.
- I didn't expect this,
I thought it was very unexpected,
but I thought okay he's
done, he got murried.
(laughs) He got murried.
- And I love the reference
of getting Murried.
- Yeah it's like what're
you talkin' about?
Jesse Eisenberg's neurotic way,
but I didn't expect
that bonus scene at all
and it was a great surprise,
and also seeing my friend Josh Horowitz
turned into a zombie.
- Our friend Grace Randolph
was in the post credit scene as well.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
No that was, I thought that was
and listen the scene with
Thomas Middleditch and Luke Wilson
as Flagstaff and Albuquerque
basically playing doppelgangers,
mirror versions of Jesse
Eisenberg and Woody Harrelson.
That scene alone makes
the movie worth seeing.
That scene alone tops the original.
Those 25 minutes is better
than the whole original film.
That scene was so inspired,
it was so much fun,
it was so different, and it
was the peak of the film.
- And what we see in this movie
is this new community Babylon
and so if we have Babylon
then there's probably
other communities like this
and I'm pretty sure we
didn't kill all the zombies
in this post apocalyptic landscape, so.
Chauncey, what could be next
for the "Zombieland" franchise?
Are we done after this,
or do you think that there's
room for another movie?
Amazon had a
pilot in 2013,
could we maybe go back
to a streaming service?
Where should "Zombieland" go?
- Well I'd like another movie.
Maybe one of the couples,
I know this gets so cliche,
but one of them is having
a baby or something,
and having to try to raise a
kid in the zombie apocalypse,
and I think that would
be kind of interesting.
One of the great things
about the franchise
is that it's very aware
of itself, it's very meta,
it makes jokes, it talked
about "The Walking Dead".
So it's very aware that it might do
a lot of the cliches so it'd be nice
to do another movie like that.
I wouldn't want a series
because I feel like we had a series
that was very similar
to what they would be
which is "Z Nation".
I thought Z Nation was very
similar, in the same vein,
which was had the comedy,
had the outlandishness,
so we kinda did that already.
- Alex is there any room
for redemption possibly
with another "Zombieland" or are you--
- Come on Alex.
- I do like the idea.
Ruben Fleischer and Jesse Eisenberg
did an AMA on Reddit
yesterday talking about,
one question was so is
"Zombieland" three in 2029?
They were like yeah that's the idea.
So I like the idea that
there's this the "Up" series,
the four sunrise, the four sunsets,
it's every 10 years, they come back
and you see where these characters are.
In a way it is meta, right?
So in the next 10 years they
can just throw a comment
on where the zombie genre has gone
and they just sort of keep on doing that.
- And we could see maybe a child pop up
somewhere in there, Scott.
- Here's what I wanna see
in "Zombieland" three.
- Pitch to the other
three cities on the panel.
- I thought "Zombieland: Double
Tap" it was a worthy sequel,
not necessarily a superior one.
I loved it for what it was, okay,
but if you're going to
do a "Zombieland" three,
just go for it.
Really Just pull out all
the stops and go for it.
Now when I think of the great
movie sequels of all time,
I mean sure there's "Godfather II",
there's "Star Trek II: The Wrath of Khan",
"Spider-Man 2"
- "Secret of the Ooze".
- Listen, nothing is better than
"Gremlins 2: The New Batch".
- I knew you were gonna
work the new batch in.
- Gremlins 2,
was so great because it was a
spoof of the original movie.
It made fun of the original film.
It pulled out all the stops.
If you've never seen "Gremlins 2",
which came out July 2nd, 1990,
the same day as "Dick Tracy",
it is a superior sequel in
every sense of the word,
and it just was a wild, wacky,
crazy, really awesome sequel.
So that's what I wanna see
for "Zombieland" three,
just go for it.
There was a little bit of meta stuff.
Like there was a joke
about "Walking Dead",
but really just have fun with it.
Maybe "Zombieland" three is about
the filming of "Zombieland" three.
- That is meta on top of meta.
- That's what I want to see.
- Reality TV?
- Do something different.
- Reality TV with zombies
I can actually buy into.
That's a meta sandwich and
we might be here for it.
More "Zombieland" in some
capacity is the consensus
that I'm getting from my panel
who by the way today was terrific.
Thank you to my guests
Scott, Chauncey, and Alex
for joining me here today to talk about
"Zombieland: Double Tap"
and I would remind everybody
out there watching right now.
We have some really good
news here at Rotten Tomatoes,
we have our first book!
Rotten Movies we love.
These are movies that are
green on the spectrum.
So technically they're rotten
according to Tomatometer,
but we love them all just the same.
"Step Brothers" made
the cover, "Spaceballs"
is sitting there at 59%.
There's so many fun Rotten movies
and you can check them
all out in this book.
There's 101 of them as a
matter of fact so get the book,
debate with your friends,
that's what we like
doing around these parts.
Thanks so much for tuning in today.
Subscribe right here
to our YouTube channel
and hit that bell.
It'll give you an alert every time
we have a new "Rotten
Tomato Show" coming out.
Thanks so much, we'll see you next time.
(upbeat rock music)